this video is sponsored by Trove if you
haven't heard of Trove yet now you have
it's a gorgeous voxel MMORPG where you
can play as one of over 17 available
classes that's free to play on Xbox
PlayStation PC and yes even the Nintendo
switch now that you're educated on this
amazing game allow me to introduce you
to its brand new expansion patch sunrise
it happened to an already humongous game
bringing to it to the brand new solarion
class new region new weapons and of
course new customization options and
mounts and pets because we all love pets
and to celebrate the release of all the
new amazing content in Sunrise the devs
are hosting a tick tock contest and
don't lie to me I know you have Tick
Tock where you can receive 1 000 viewers
for cosplaying one of the characters and
getting the video with the most likes
what's that in American money you ask
about 994 dollars and even if you don't
win you'll still get some amazing
special Loot and rewards in game so what
are you waiting for try out tro for free
on whatever console you want to while
we're all waiting for breath of the wild
to play the new Sunrise update with your
friends and get cracking on some cosplay
for money and loot link is in the
description below and now on to the
video
a Zelda game without bosses is like a
bowl of ramen with only noodles it's
like yeah it's a bowl those are ramen
noodles but where's the flavor where's
the succulent meat where's those little
swirly looking things that are sometimes
making appearances in the bowl bosses
are a big part of what makes Zelda games
so memorable just like other ingredients
are to Ramen noodles and for loreheads
like myself they're also a very good way
to deepen one's understanding of the
in-universe lore of the games so in this
video I'm gonna go over all of the
unique or major bosses and minibosses in
Ocarina of Time and briefly explain
their existence because let's face it
it's been 24 years since it was released
and there are probably lots of people
out there who haven't played it oh and
expect spoilers obviously let's begin
with the very first set of bosses in the
game Queen Goma King dadongo and
baronade all three of these bosses were
the direct result of Ganondorf throwing
a fit because nobody would give him the
spiritual Stones first he wanted the
Kokiri Emerald from the Deku Tree and
when the Great Deku Tree refused
Ganondorf cursed it with a literal Giant
spider monster known as the armored
parasite Goma in order to sap the tree
of its power and literally kill it which
he succeeds at actually now Ganondorf
himself is a powerful sorcerer capable
of Performing great acts of dark magic
so this means that Goma originated from
one of two places either one gomu was
created out of thin air by Ganondorf to
curse and sap the Deku Tree or two
Ganondorf used his dark powers to evolve
a normal spider into the humongous
monster Goma although this doesn't
really matter much in the grand scheme
of things and can be left up to personal
interpretation because the end result is
the same next up we have the boss of the
dongo's cavern King dadongo similarly to
Goma King dadonga was heavily implied to
be the result of a curse from Ganondorf
according to the leader of the Goron's
darunia Ganondorf also asked him for the
Goron's Ruby but was once again denied
the spiritual Stone prompting the desert
king to fill the cavern with quote
ancient creatures and seal it shut with
a giant boulder in the entrance
preventing the gorons from accessing the
Finger Licking Good rocks inside now
given that the dunga's cavern had no
dudangos in it before ganondorf's curse
and given that these ancient creatures
that darunia is talking about are in
fact the dongos and King dadongo himself
this means that tadango's Cavern once
had to dongos in it hence its name
possibly even one as big as the skull
present in the dungeon but they were all
cleared out Long Ago by ancient gorons
or rather by an ancient heroic Goron in
particular but more on that later this
means that Ganondorf must have
resurrected that adangos from their
ancient tombs and by extension King
dedango himself with dark magic in order
to punish the gorans for not giving him
the stone King dadongo had a short
second lifespan though next we have the
anemone anemone baronade which was
responsible for putting jabu jabu in
such a bad mood once again this seems to
be the direct result of ganondorf's
curse since King Zora confirms that
jabba jabba was different and sickly
following ganondorf's visit the Gerudo
likely asked about the spiritual Stone
and was given an unsatisfying answer
since the stone was actually in
possession of the Zora Princess Ruto and
similarly to Goma marinade leech to the
life of jabu-jabu parasitically and
might have even killed jabu-jabu if it
wasn't for the big fish literally
swallowing the hero of time points to
link for being a more effective
painkiller than Ibuprofen now it's time
to grow up after link turns into an
adult seven years have passed and once
again Ganondorf has been running around
setting bosses in places they shouldn't
be this is again true of the first
second and third temples which feature
Phantom Ganon volvagia the dragon and
the water tentacle monster morpha
Phantom Ganon was an apparition created
by Ganondorf for the purposes of
stopping link from saving Seria from the
curse of the Forest Temple which
awakened her as a sage however it should
be noted that Ganondorf knowingly made
his doppelganger ghost a bit less
powerful than he himself is possibly
because he knew from the get-go that he
would need to let link live in order to
come into the castle himself and reveal
the Triforce of Courage but that's
speculative volvagia was another case of
the Dead being brought back to life by
the hand of Ganondorf and like I
mentioned earlier volvagia himself was
actually slain Long Ago by agoron Hero
using the fabled Megaton hammer
according to link that not this link the
Goron named afterlink known as link
anyway volvagia was a dragon that lived
inside Death Mountain as its protector
spirit and is even said to be the
ancestor of velu the protector Spirit of
dragon Roost Mountain allegedly he was
always rather aggressive and as such the
ancient Goron hero saw fit to smash him
two Smithereens with a giant hammer and
once Ganondorf became ruler of the land
he decided he would make a spectacle of
the gorons and feed them one by one as
snacks to the freshly revived volvagia
in order to scare the other hyrulean
races into Obedience of course link has
something to say about this the final
boss that Ganondorf is solely
responsible for creating would be the
very strange aquatic amoeba morpha which
Ganondorf placed inside the water temple
in order to both free zor's domain and
its inhabitants and drain Lake hylia of
its water whenever given an explicit
reason as to why Ganondorf Soul royally
screwed over the Zoro people but it can
be assumed that it was in order to Halt
the progress of the water Sage's
Awakening now with ganondorf's many
Creations out of the way let's move on
to the bosses that have their own reason
for being you know bosses back in the
Forest Temple there's a group of Poe
sisters that haunts the area known as
the poe sisters these ghostly girls
don't have an explained backstory
present anywhere in the game but it can
be assumed that their Spirits have been
bound to the Forest Temple for quite
some time since there are portraits of
the ghosts located within its
castle-like walls it's also interesting
to note that each of the girls Joe Beth
Amy and Meg are named after the four
sisters from the novel Little Women this
implies that they weren't created as
pose but were once actually living
people and since Poes are heavily
implied to be evil spirits regardless of
their once peaceful Natures who are
Tethered to the living world because of
some unresolved attachment we can also
assume that the girls were probably all
murdered in this Temple before their
natural deaths and may have actually
been friendly when they were alive next
up let's take a look at the infamous
miniboss of the water temple Dark Link
dark link is without a doubt probably
the most popular Zelda enemy other than
Ganondorf himself and for good reason
evil doppelganger types are always
popular anime across all kinds of media
since it's a great question that Navi
also raises in the game how exactly are
you supposed to conquer yourself is that
even possible from a philosophical
standpoint regardless I'd like to point
out that one thing that people confuse a
lot is the identity of Dark Link shown
here with that of Link's Shadow from a
link to the past or the shadow links
from other games simply put those other
inverted link enemies that look similar
are actually completely different in
both their Origins and their purposes
now keep in mind that there are many
different Dark Link origin theories out
there for Ocarina of Time some of which
are very good that you are more than
welcome to believe if you so desire but
I'm going to explain what I think his
origin story is from a very realistic
and somewhat boring point of view which
will differ from several of those Series
this darkling in Ocarina of Time which
is where the name darkling comes from
was most likely placed here indirectly
by whoever made the temple in the first
place see the water temple was created
as a place where the Zora could worship
the water spirits but it's also clear
that it was designed to be a trial as
well what trials in Zelda games are
unheard of but it's true because unlike
the other temples where it's more or
less about link finding his way to the
end of whatever structure he's in the
water temple specifically shows you the
end right off the bat and instead
requires intelligent manipulation of
water levels and going back and forth
between its many rooms and hidden
compartments in order to solve its Grand
puzzle and access the final area just
outside of your reach and perhaps the
solution of the temple is in and of
itself how the Zora worshiped the water
spirits that being said this also means
that the room in which we Face Dark Link
was created as part of this big trial
along with the room's mechanics this
room is illusory it creates false images
that make you think it has no walls and
that the floor is covered by a very
reflective surface of water emphasis on
reflective which is the point of this
particular trial it's my interpretation
that the purpose of this room is to test
the worshiper traversing through the
water temple with a challenge of
Conquering the reflective Darkness
within themselves in order to purify
themselves for the water Spirits after
all Navi doesn't imply that Dark Link is
its own entity like she does with every
other monster in the game if anything
she acts like Dark Link is just an
extension of Link himself and since Dark
Link appears to originate from the tree
in the middle of the room and reflects
Link's appearance and moveset it's my
personal interpretation that the fruit
of the tree if you will is a watery
reflection of the individual who would
Brave the trials of the temple in order
to seek purification from its Waters
this is why Dark Link exists and is a
boss at least an Ocarina of Time number
next we have the minibus of the Shadow
Temple and boss of the area beneath the
well and subject of many nightmares the
Dead Hand now previously the Dead Hand
and the Shadow Temple itself were hugely
speculated over but ever since the
release of the Hyrule encyclopedia we've
gotten a confirmed answer as to where
the spooky Temple came from it was built
as a place for the sheikah to capture
and torture the enemies of the royal
family which would explain the you know
torture devices and Pages it marks such
a Dark and Bloody time for the history
of Hyrule that the royal family is
actually forbidden to even speak of it
of course there are many other Mysteries
present in the temple but that's another
video for another day dead hands
presence in this old chica Temple can
only be due to one of two things either
one the Dead Hand is the result of dark
sheikah experiments in order to create
some sort of hungry Undead man-eating
monster with which to feed their
subjects too to get rid of them after
they were done torturing them for
information explaining the dead hand
chamber and many human bones present in
it or two the Dead Hand was
supernaturally created from the
aforementioned many corpses that lie in
the Shadow Temple walls when the dark
power of Bongo Bongo was released and
added to the temple cursing it and
giving rise to the undead within this
would explain why the Dead Hand
initially pops up underneath the well
and its dead appearance with the bleach
white blood-stained skin and its human
skull head it would also explain the
ability for Dead Hand to summon infinite
numbers of hands to grab hold of its
victims with though I personally favor
the first explanation due to the fact
that there are two dead hands in the
game and playing pretty heavily that
they were purposefully created and
placed in chica torture chambers and
speaking of the Shadow Temple its final
boss Bongo Bongo is also shrouded in
mystery for those who don't know Bongo
Bongo is an evil spirit whose appearance
is similar to that of a hanging beheaded
man with a giant eye in its neck and cut
off hands that just can't help but play
the drums Bongo Bunga was sealed within
the well by the sheikah leader impa but
broke out when the darkness grew too
powerful and this is most likely because
of the rise of ganondorf's power since
he is in fact the leader of the forces
of evil where Bongo Bongo came from
initially though is again widely
speculated over but I have a more
realistic take on its origin many people
assume that the man whose house used to
be located where the well sits now is
the real identity of Bongo Bongo and
this may or may not be true one thing's
for certain though and that is that
Bongo Bongo is a spirit a big Spirit not
to be overly simplistic but we do see
what spirits of the Dead look like as
far as size is concerned in the game
their pose and they all almost always
end up being smaller or thinner than the
average human but in some cases we come
across pose that are far bigger than the
others called Big pose and one of the
biggest pose in particular is the boss
named jalhala from the Wind Waker
jalhala is so massive because he's
composed of other smaller pose so here's
the question what if Bongo Bongo the
evil Shadow Spirit is such a massive
entity because he's composed of the
spirits of many dead people and you know
where a bunch of dead people were made
in the middle of kakariko under the well
and within the Shadow Temple
conveniently where Bongo Bongo
originated from my personal
interpretation is that the dead hands
killed so many people that their
combined lingering hateful Spirits
manifested as the Phantom shower the
Phantom Shadow Beast Bongo Bongo whose
hands were cut off due to the spirits of
the Dead being Shackled in life and
whose head was cut off to signify their
executions moving on to the next Temple
the spirit Temple dedicated to the sand
goddess located within the guru desert
also The Hideout for Ganondorf and his
followers before he rose to power and
moved to the floating Hyrule Castle the
mini bosses of the temple are the iron
Knuckles which have a pretty simple
explanation they're brainwashed Garuda
women in suits of heavy armor swinging
massive weapons and honestly I don't
have a problem believing that they could
physically do that because have you seen
their biceps but the bigger question is
who is responsible for brainwashing
these poor women well that would be the
boss bosses of the temple the twin witch
sisters known separately as kotake and
kaume or together as twin rova according
to the lore twin rova is ganondorf's
surrogate mother slash mothers and since
there's actually two of them and their
sisters I personally feel like the term
surrogate mother used here actually
means more like adoptive mothers rather
than the other meaning of a surrogate
mother which includes a woman birthing a
child for another woman who can't that
being said it makes sense then that twin
rovo would be such a devout follower of
Ganondorf they're just proud to see
their little boy grow up to be the evil
King he was always meant to be what a
cutie they're also both over 400 years
old and apparently go to heaven when
they die huh they must have helped other
old ladies across the street when they
were alive the final boss of this game
is none other than Ganondorf himself who
transforms into Ganon after his initial
defeat most people know ganondorf's
backstory even if they haven't played
Ocarina of Time but I'll go over it
anyway Ganondorf was the last known male
Gerudo born to the Gerudo race that's
historically been entirely female well
mostly female it was said that once
every hundred years a boy would be born
and that boy would be the Gerudo King
which is why Ganondorf is the last
Gerudo King however since he kind of
tried to end the world ever since
ganondorf's defeat at the end of Ocarina
of Time and Wind Waker and Twilight
Princess and a link to the past the
Gerudo women have completely sworn off
men even those of their own race and as
such they are now for all intents and
purposes entirely composed of women if
there have been male Garuda born since
the time of Ganondorf it has been
undocumented and unconfirmed and they
have been banished from their own
Homeland which is why their existence
these days is Theory a believable Theory
but a theory nonetheless but back to
Ganondorf in Wind Waker we're able to
get a better understanding of why
Ganondorf did what he did in regards to
overthrowing the Hylian royal family he
was jealous the Gerudo desert is a harsh
environment and ultimately as the grito
king he wanted the lands or Winds of
Hyrule to be the new home for his people
which seems Noble but he absolutely went
about it the wrong way and somewhere
along the way lost sight of his
Democratic Ambitions and instead began
to covet the ultimate power known as the
Triforce in order to subjugate the
entire world to his will forcefully
initially Ganondorf swears allegiance to
the king of Hyrule in order to craftily
locate the Triforce for himself but
celaduses through his lies and asks link
to help her with getting rid of the man
with the evil eyes since you know you
can't count on the king of Hyrule to do
something like that after Link and Zelda
opened the door of time to find the
master sword and thus the entrance to
the sacred realm Ganondorf actually
predicted that they would do this and
gains free access to the Triforce within
the sacred realm and attempts to take it
for himself however due to the imbalance
within his own heart the Triforce splits
into its three separate pieces of power
wisdom and courage each then residing
within Ganondorf Zelda and Link
respectively as they represented those
individual attributes the most after
this happened Ganondorf wanted to find
the other two pieces to reform the
completed Triforce and thus regain
ultimate power but with Zelda being in
hiding and Link fast asleep for seven
years he had to come up with another
plan in order to locate the missing
pieces and just like Ganondorf had link
do his work for him seven years ago once
again link located Zelda and her
Triforce of wisdom and brought the
Triforce of Courage himself directly to
Ganondorf without the Gerudo usurper
ever having to leave his throne room
which he predicted again of course link
is able to defeat Ganondorf which he did
not predict who tries to bring the
castle down on top of Lincoln Zelda in
another attempt to kill them when this
fails Ganondorf who I guess was still
not dead calls upon the Triforce of
power to transform into the pig-like
monster known as Ganon who lives for
about 40 seconds since the hero of time
with the the blade of Evil's vein was
standing like two feet away and proceeds
to kill Ganon immediately who then
reverts back to Ganondorf who then
becomes sealed away temporarily but for
the remainder of this game simply put
Ganon is the demonic form that Ganondorf
transforms into that embodies his lust
for power and as far as the timeline's
concerned this is the very moment that
Ganon was created who just as a reminder
we still haven't been able to rid the
world of to this day I personally
believe that Ganon is the embodiment of
the curse that demise places upon hylia
back in the events of Skyward Sword and
that Ganondorf was able to access this
power through the Triforce of power but
that's just my personal head Cannon
ultimately this is all kind of the
goddess's fault since they're the ones
who decided to leave an all-powerful
Relic in the hands of mere mortals
anyway but alas we are not destined to
understand the whims of the gods that
being said though this concludes the
explanation of all the bosses from
Ocarina of Time and I'm curious did you
learn something new or did you know all
this stuff before watching let me know
in the comments below and please
consider leaving a like if you enjoyed
the video if the turnout's decent I'll
continue this idea with the other Zelda
game games like Twilight Princess and
The Wind Waker so be sure to subscribe
if you haven't already to stick around
for those and many more video game
videos to come huge thanks as always to
my Bandicoot who are the reason I can
continue to make these videos and if
you'd like to help out too check out the
links in the description to find out how
or head over to my Kofi page to figure
out how to get me to review your
theories in a video that's all I've got
for this one so as always I hope you
have a wonderful rest of your day this
is Bandit looking forward to seeing you
next time and signing out peace
[Music]
thank you